bon or à toutes et à tous
un prix le livre et moi ces questions
d'amour
je voudrais
ici est un sport rendre hommage à des
personnes qui m'ont fait rêver qui
sont dans cette salle je vois la grande
soeur madame si je vous demande a clamé
le ministre justin morel junior merci
grand frère
et mon professeur mettait qui l'a oublié
mais c'est un autre modèle les amis du
futur à blaye robin maltais
ils m'ont fait rêver et je vous ai dit
entre le livre et moi ces questions
d'amour
comme on a dit dans ma petite
présentation
moi je suis originaire de caen
qu'encore qu'il ya une ville je pense y
181 700 km de conakry je suis né en 1977
d'un père enseignant
après qui a fait la librairie et qui a
créé des bibliothèques aucun cas ce
grand monsieur m'a transmis quoi l'amour
de la famille et le livre je voudrais à
cet instant lui rendent hommage
puisqu'il est décédé son petit nom était
bonne tout m'a dit
ma petite bio vous verrez des choses
qu'on a dites ici mais je voudrais vous
parler de mon livre de chevet
est enfin la routine et je pense que
l'enfant noir marqué à vie ce livre je
les lui réélu et je continue je viens
d'avoir la version bande dessinée et
bientôt il y aura des choses
exceptionnelles sur ce livre a recruté
guinée jeunes auteurs que j'admire
parce qu'on se rend compte très souvent
qui est un auteur congolais jean tu fais
coucou à ma grande soeur alain mabanckou
par l'audace qu'il dégage
lorsque j'étais étudiant j'ai imaginé
j'avais de l'ambition j'ai créé ce qu'on
appelait alors les amis du futur c'était
de la mission parce que notre credo
était comme un skate ensemble on peut
construire l'avenir de cette nation
parce que la guinée nous inquiétait
beaucoup moi j'avais pas de cas et de
souvenirs mais j'ai j'avais des fiches
de souvenirs grand frère en terminale au
lycée en mathématiques a qu'un kg
sélectionné cinq cent de mes amis j'ai
élaboré des fiches tous ses amis m'ont
parlé de leur rêve c'est qu'il
souhaitait faire et c'est ce qui a donné
en 90 secondes de parc a pris 1,19 ici
les amis du futur nos invités quelque
chose imaginez mais avec beaucoup de
lecture
je voudrais partager avec vous puisque
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit quelques
livres qui sont dans ma bibliothèque à
la maison pour ceux qui souhaiteraient
les avoirs vous pouvez venir on peut
échanger
les misérables de victor hugo je vous
invite vivement
je vois des amis français qui sont dans
cette salle madame bovary
le journal d'anne frank et livre
magnifique que tout jeune va pouvoir
lire le parfum je vous inviterai et tous
ses livres aujourd'hui il ya des grands
films qui sont adaptés de ces livres là
qu'ils ont tirés de ses lives je vais
pas pouvoir vous citer tous mais
l'exercice était pour vous montrer qu'à
travers le livre on peut faire on peut
se construire on peut faire des choses
exceptionnelles
aussi il ya des films qui m'ont marqué
et j'inviterai les jeunes qui sont dans
cette salle les regarde et de les
regarder et de s'inspirer de ces livres
est de ces films et clips pour exister
un film magnifique qui parle des choses
de la vie des choses qu'on doit dans sa
vie vraiment comment se construit nous
étoiles contraire indian palace 1 2 je
pense même le 3 est sorti bonus vous mes
frères et soeurs qui sont dans cette
valve coexister
c'est magnifique
intouchable qu'est ce qu'on a fait au
bon dieu et à propos de ce film
j'inviterais beaucoup les jeunes vignes
ma soeur est là pendant l'année du livre
on a fait défiler tous ces films là
pendant l'année du livre en république
de guinée
tout ça dit et pour faire quoi
cité pour apprendre à faire des choses
exceptionnelles réalisées une ambition
quand j'étais jeune élève à kaka je
voyais qu'en côte d'ivoire des choses
exceptionnelles se faisait au burkina au
sénégal
dans beaucoup de villes africaines
mais je me disais qu'est-ce que nous
indigner on pouvait faire la grande
serez là on avait l'accord à on avait le
djembé il ya eu des festivals de ces
instruments là en guinée mais après les
autres ont pris tout ça moi j'ai choisi
le livre je me suis dit qu'à travers le
livre on peut faire des choses
exceptionnelles et c'est pourquoi j'ai
choisi de créer une entreprise je
pouvais choisir d'être avec l'état à la
direction du livre ou bien au ministère
de la culture à la direction et tout ça
mais je me suis dit le choix de la
liberté est fondamental pour réussir des
choses exceptionnelles donc j'ai décidé
à rentrer entre mes études en france de
créer une entreprise de draguignan pour
pouvoir réaliser
vraiment mes rêves en septembre 2006
ducret les éditions l'harmattan parce
que j'étais choqué quand j'arrivais à
paris
je voyais la côte d'ivoire il y avait
des listes de livres dans les rayons le
mali exceptionnel le sénégal quand
j'arrivais au niveau de la guinée
s'étaient sentis sept livres c'était
choquant je me suis dis qu'il faut
transformer ça il faut faire en sorte
qu'en guinée les gens puissent écrire et
pouvoir publié en septembre 2006 je
crains les éditions l'harmattan
aujourd'hui nous avons près de 1000
collaborateurs
700 titres 15 électeurs de collection et
près de 400 auteurs
créé cette entreprise
j'ai compris tout de suite qui avait pas
d' espace de promotion il faut créer cet
espace les salons se faisaient encore
une fois à ouagadougou abidjan à bamako
j'ai imaginé le salon du livre de
conakry kg de nommer les 72 heures du
livre le thème de la première édition
c'était le livre à venir de la guinée
parce que je savais qu'à travers le
livre on pourrait sauver notre pays et
notre histoire les 72 heures aujourd'hui
c'est très édition c'est près de 500
auteurs invités dix pays invité
d'honneur
et près de 2 millions de visiteurs parce
que lorsqu'on organise l'événement à
conakry les jeunes les étudiants les
élèves viennent de gauche à droite après
nous traversons pour aller dans une
ville invitée d'honneur
après cette étape de ma cabine
d'étudiants en france je savais que le
23 avril était la journée mondiale du
livre et qu'à cet instant chaque 23
avril hinwil du monde devenait capitale
mondiale du livre je me suis dit
pourquoi pas un jour qu'un capitales
mondiales c'était ça l'idée mais je
savais qu'à quinquin les infrastructures
ne pouvait pas accueillir
c'est pourquoi on doit travailler encore
dans notre pays donc j'ai pensé à
conakry j'ai commencé à réfléchir j'ai
mis 10 à préparer le dossier 10 ans et
après dix ans on a déposé le dossier à
l'unesco vraiment nous avons réussi le
travail d'une véritable équipe
qu'on a créé capitale mondiale du livre
c'était 60 et 365 jours un livre dans le
pays on a associé le livre à tous la
république n'est pas ce qu'on voulait
rendre le livre fait si c'était ça notre
rêve c'est une bibliothèque nationale le
grand frère et ministre d'alors on a
fait une bibliothèque à l'intérieur de
gamal abdel nasser mais c'était pas ça
le rêve il faut qu'en guinée qu'on rêve
d'une véritable bibliothèque nationale
mais cette bibliothèque existe
aujourd'hui c'est la rénovation de la
biotech du professeur guy breton signal
c'est des points de lecture dans les
quartiers de conakry c'est les salles de
lecture c'est aussi près de 5 millions
de livres que nous avons distribué des
ong des entreprises des partenaires nous
ont envoyé des livres en guinée et nous
avons dû oublier dans tout le pays la
prochaine étape j'examine j'invite et
c'est de faire de conakry la capitale
africaine du livre c'est ça notre vision
et construire par le livre nous allons
faire en sorte que l'industrie du livre
puisse exister dans notre pays faire en
sorte que les livres puissent être édité
ici imprimés ici traduit dans les
langues africaines
faire en sorte que le plus grand
monument du livre en afrique soit
installée dans notre pays qu'il aime
user du livre a reculé guinée qui chaque
deux ans en plus vraiment faire la
biennale africain du livre donc voilà la
vision voilà c'est qu'on souhaite à
travers le livre on peut garantir
l'avenir parce que c'est des emplois
c'est du travail c'est des choses
exceptionnelles pour la guinée et je
sais qu'on peut compter pour sur chacun
d'entre vous ici je termine en vous
faisant passer une petite vidéo qui va
vous parler de cire que le livre peut
apporter à notre nation
[Musique]
merci à toutes et à tous notre prochaine
des fiches vous voulez dit c'est de
faire de conakry la capitale africaine
du livre avec le livre comme outil les
diplomaties je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci bon